how do people identify when it's occult  well you go to the meeting and you see a  big portrait of the leader on the wall  that's a real red flag and everybody is  talking over and over again about how  great the leader is and you realize that  the leader is what it's all about and  that they worship the leader and that  the leader is the core a defining  element of the group everyone only views  the leader through a positive lens no  one ever disagrees with the leader and  you feel like there's no legitimate  reason to leave and that anybody who  leaves is characterized in a negative  light you also recognize that people are  becoming socially isolated and they're  not really in touch with maybe their  family their old friends everything is  black and white nothing in Shades of  Gray and so the group kind of create  environment where everything the leader  says is reinforced and nothing is ever  questioned